الله
اكبر
لا اله الا
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد
لله كثيرا
را وسبحان
الله
بكره
واصيلا وصلى الله على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
[Silence]
‏the light on
‏orang
[Silence]
الله اكبر ولله
السلام عليكم
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم سيد
زينوا اعيادكم بالتكبير
انذا هذا هو افضل يوم في
العام يوم
النحر الله سبحانه وتعالى يباهي فيكم
الملائكه ديكوريت يور
عيد والتكبير بليز
سنه حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم طلب من الصحابه ان يرفعوا اصواتهم في
التكبير ان شاء الله
سويا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
والله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز ز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا نا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى انصار سيد
سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
والله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والح الحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق
وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم تسليما ما
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
لله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
كبيرا والحمد الحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده واحزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد
على اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
كثيراث
الله اكبر الله
لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر
والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
وسيله لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جده
وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الاجا مخلصين له
الدين
কাফন আল্লাহুম্মা সাল্লি আলা
সাই্যদিনা মুহাম্মাদ
وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى اصار سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما
كثيرا
كثيرا আসসালামু
আলাইকুম আসসালামু
আলাইকুম
তাকবনে 5 মিনিট
and
start
cle any me distப
আফাসফার
অফার
ইনশল্লাহ
কব মিনিট
after
আল্লাহু আকবার
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله والله
اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كثيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر عبده
واعز جنده وحزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الاك
مخلصين له
الدين
ولا
الكافرون السلام
عليكم السلام
عليكم இইনে
‏so pleas stand up for a minut and come
cler to each other just as the rose for
the pray that will make it eas for new
people coming
in anybody who
is today you can take the me to either
the abu hanfa mask or bring it here both
places have been set up with the
freezers insyaallah
‏make small as much as you
and
make
الله
اكبر
الا
والله
اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق
وعده ونصر صر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
كثيرا সিস্টার আসসালামু
আলাইকুম
সার্টিং
শলিউমেন্ট মিংহ
‏make the
meest manag and them set up for both
loc
and mask on fth so take place and
distribute thatইশল্লাহ also there is
after the second খুবা which is for 9 we
will have the bref avilable here and
there
‏pleas pleas makeஜই
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
ما بذ
ستر عيدكم
مبارك صلاه
العيد
وذ امام ابو
حنيفه
سكول
تكبيرات ذا اكسترا
تكبيرات ستارت و هاف فور
تكبيره ستارت
تكبيره افتر تكبيره
الاحرام سوره
الفاتحه
سوره
ركعه الفاتحه
سوره تكبيرات
تكبيره
تكبيرهركوع جزاكم الله خير بالعربي
سنصلي على مذهب الامام ابي حنيفه النعمان
وكل وكلهم من رسول الله
ملتمسون في الركعه الاولى بعد تكبيره
الاحرام ساكبر ثلاث تكبيرات اضافيه وترفع
الايدي في التكبيرات ترفع الا من السنه
رفع اليدين في
التكبيرات
ثم ا ساقرا الفاتحه وسوره
معها في الركعه
الثانيه سابدا بقراءه سوره الفاتحه وسوره
معها ثم ابدا بثلاث تكبيرات وترفع الايدي
معها
ثم اذهب في التكبيره الرابعه ساذهب الى
الركوع جزاكم الله خير استووا واستقيموا
الى الصلاه يرحمكم
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغض المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى
ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يخشى ويتجن
الاشقى الذي
يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والفجر
وليال
عشر والشفع والوتر
الليل اذا
يسر هل في ذلك قسم لذي
حجر الم تر كيف فعل ربك
بعاد ارم ذات
العماد التي لم يخلق مثلها في
البلاد وثمود الذين جابوا الصخر
بالواد وفرعون ذي
الاوتاد الذين طغوا في البلاد
فاكثروا فيها
الفساد فصب عليهم ربك صوت
عذاب ان ربك
لبالمرصاد الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا اله الا
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الا والله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا الله ولا نعبد الا اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون الحمد
لله حمدا يوافي
نعمه ويكافئ
مزيده ويدفع عنا
بلاءه
ونقمه لك الحمد يا ربنا حتى ترضى ولا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله العلي
العظيم عباد
الله اوصيكم ونفسي اولا بتقوى الله تعالى
وطاعته ولزوم اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها
المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان التقوى
شعار
المؤمنين ودثار
الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم
اجمعين فقد قال الله سبحانه وت
تعالى
وتزودوا فان خير الزاد
التقوى واتقوني يا اولي
الالباب يقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى في قصه من قصص القران
الكريم في سوره
الصافات يذكر
ر حال نبي من
انبيائه
بل يشرد لنا القران
الكريم قصه ابو
الانبياء مع ابنه اسماعيل عليه
السلام
القران ما سور
[Silence]
ابراهم اسماعيل عليه
السلام الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان سوره
الصافات ايه
نمبر تو
نمبر فلما
لما بلغ معه
السعي قال يا
بني اني ارى في المنام اني
اذبحك فانظر ماذا
ترى قال يا ابت افعل ما
تؤمر ستجدني ان شاء الله من
الصابرين
فلما اسلم وتله للجب
وناديناه يا
ابراهيم قد صدقت
الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين ان هذا لهو البلاء
المبين
وفديناه بذبح عظيم
‏will
my from
the so
[Silence]
ابراهيم عليه
‏my عليه
السلام which you are comm
[Silence]
‏when they
both had
him on
for
him ابراهام
[Silence]
‏tri
and
him
sacriice and we for
سلام
ابراهم
سلام على
ابراهيم ايها
المسلمون ذس ايات
[Silence]
وفي هذا اليوم
العظيم اجتمع
عيدان في يوم
واحد عيد الاضحى
المبارك ويوم
الجمعه
لذا من الواجب
علي ان ابين
لكم الامور
الفقهيه عندما يجتمع عيدان وابين لكم
احكام
العيد من هذه
الاحكام صلاه
العيد
وهي واجبه
عند
الحنفيه وقول عند
الحنابله وسنه
مؤكده عند المالكيه
والشافعيه اما صلاه
الجمعه فهي فرض
عين على كل مسلم
مقيم
صحيح وقد رخص النبي صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم لمن يسكنون البوادي
والاعالي وخارج
المدن لان
الاصل انه لا جمعه
عليهم اما المقيم في المدن فتجب عليه
الجمعه ولا توجد له رخصه
بقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وانا
مجمعون عيد الاضحى
[Silence]
حنفي حنبلي
شافعي صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
‏principle
notay frid
prayers
as frid prayers
صلى الله عليه وسلممام
[Silence]
الاضحيه ايها
المسلمون اعلموا
ان الله
تعالى غني
عنا ولا
يحتاج
ذبائحنا ولا
لحومنا يقول الله تعالى في سوره الحج ايه
37 لن ينال الله
لحومها ولا
دماؤها ولكن يناله التقوى
منكم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى اعلموا عباد
الله ان جمهور
العلماء قالوا ان
الاضحيه سنه
مؤكده
وشرعت شكرا لله
تعالى
واحياء لسنه
سيدنا ابراهيم
الخليل
وابنه اسماعيل عليهما الصلاه
والسلام
واتباعا لحبيبنا وسيدنا محمد صلى الله
عليه واله وسلم عندما قال خذوا عني
مناسككم كما ان فيها تعظيما لشعائر الله
سبحانه
وتعالى قال الله تعالى ذلك ومن يعظم
شعائر
الله فانها من تقوى
القلوب سنه
سنه
ابرام خليل
الله
اسماعيل محمد صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
الله
لذا
يشترط ان تكون
الاضحيه سليمه من العيوب
الظاهره التي تعد
نقصا فيها فقد روى ابو داوود وغيره عن
البراء بن عازب رضي الله
عنه ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
اربع لا تجوز في
الاضاحي
العوراء البين عورها والمريضه البين مرضها
والعرجاء
البين ضلعها والكثيره التي لا
تنقي وهي اي الاضحيه ما يذبح من الابل ما
بلغ خمس
سنوات او من البقر ما بلغ
السنتين او من الغنم ما بلغ اكثر من سته
اشهر او الماعز ما بلغ السنه تقري تقربا
الى الله تعالى يوم العيد ايرذاك
[Silence]
الاضحيه
الله سبحانه
وتعالى عيد الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد تكبيرات
التشريق وهذا عند العلماء
يسمى التكبير
المقيد والتشريق
معناه انه كان في ذلك
الزمان
يشرقون اللحوم بعد ان يضحوا
بها
وصيغتها هي
التكبير بصوت مسموع بعد كل صلاه
مفروضه ابتداء من فجر عرفه الى اخر يوم
العيد بعد صلاه العصر وهو قول جمهور
العلماء رحمهم الله تعالى
وصيغتها الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
فورم
تكبير عرفه
عيد
[Silence]
الفطر
تكبير الاصل في
التكبير ما روي في قصه قصه الذبيح اسماعيل
عليه
السلام ان الخليل صلوات الله عليه لما اخذ
في مقدمات الذبح جاءه جبريل عليه السلام
بالفداء فلما انتهى الى سماء الدنيا خاف
عليه
العجله فقال جبريل الله اكبر الله اكبر
فسمعه ابراهيم عليه سلام فرفع راسه فلما
علم انه جاء بالفداء قال ابراهيم لا اله
الا الله والله اكبر فسمع الذبيح اسماعيل
صلوات الله عليه فقال الله اكبر ولله
الحمد فاصبحت سنه الى يوم
القيامه ايها
المسلمون ان يومكم هذا يوم
عظيم ونذكر
فيه وفي هذا
المقام اخواننا
الحجاج
نغبطهم على ما يسر الله لهم وهم يؤدون
مناسكهم مكبرين الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله والله اكبر ولله الحمد
وملبين نداء الله تعالى لبيك اللهم لبيك
لبيك لا شريك لك لبيك ان الحمد والنعمه لك
والملك لا شريك لك كذا والطواف بالبيت
العتيق والسعي بين الصفا والمروه قال صلى
الله عليه وسلم ان اعظم الايام عند الله
تبارك وتعالى يوم النحر نسال الله تعالى
ان يتقبل منهم وان ييسر
امورهم وان يعيدهم الى بلدانهم
سالمين بالاجر
غانمين مقبولين عند الله تعالى الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون
بالاجابه
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الحمد لله حق حمده والصلاه
والسلام على من لا نبي من بعده واعلموا
عباد الله ان الله تعالى امرنا بامر بدا
فيه بنفسه وثنى بملائكه قدسه وثلث
بالمؤمنين من عالم جنه وانسه وقال تعالى
قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر نبينا وتفهيما لنا
وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما اللهم صل
على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
وبارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين
انك حميد مجيد ايها
المسلمون لا يغيبوا على
حضراتكم ما يعانيه اخواننا في
فلسطين نعيش بامن
وامان ولكنهم
هناك
يقتلون ويش
يشردون ويقذفون
بالقنابل لا ماوى
لهم نسال الله
تعالى ان يمكن
لهم وان ينصرهم على الصهاينه
المجرمين وان يرحم
شهدائهم وان يشفي
جرحاهم وان ياوي نازحيهم
اللهم يا حي ويا
قيوم توجهنا اليك في هذه الساعه
المباركه ان تفرج عن امه سيدنا محمد وان
تنصر امه سيدنا محمد وان تعين امه سيدنا
محمد وان تمكن امه سيدنا محمد يا حي ويا
قيوم برحمتك نستغيث
ليس لنا ربا سواه
فندعوك ندعوك فاستجب اللهم
دعائنا وتقبل اللهم
رجائنا ولا تردنا بعد الدعاء خائبين اللهم
من اراد بالمسلمين سوء فاجعل دائره السوء
تدور عليه اللهم فرج هم المهمومين ونفس
كرب المكروبين واقض دين
المديونين وفك اسر الماسورين والمسجونين
يا رب
العالمين ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم وتب
علينا يا مولانا انك انت التواب
الرحيم ربنا
اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا
عذاب النار عيدكم مبارك اعاده الله علينا
وعليكم بالخير والبركه واليمن والايمان
والسلامه والاسلام
والاطمئنان وكل عام وانتم بخير كبروا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
حقصح شاء
[Silence]
شاء عار
ما شاء الله ما شاء
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
السلام عليكم
ابوك وانتم طيبون
[Silence]
على
السلام عليكم
ابراهيم ما شاء
[Silence]
جزاك السلام
مبارك
[Silence]
مبارك السلام
محمد
[Silence]
السلام
‏need
[Silence]
الله
‏need
[Silence]
بينكم